Okay,
this is the most practical of all the
things that we've discussed so far.
Um,
it's really,
you could consider it a component of
industrial organizational psychology,
but it's a component that has a strong
emphasis on individual differences and
so you could consider it
first an exploration of the practical
utility of psychological concepts in
predicting real world phenomena,
but you could also consider it a part of
the validation of the psychometric
models of personality that we've
described because one of the things that
you want to do to determine whether or
not a construct.
So what's a hypothetic hypothetical
social psychological phenomena or
entity,
whether or not that's real depends to
some degree on what it's good for.
Right?
Part of the aim of science is prediction
and control and so
it's useful to take a look at important
life outcomes among human beings and to
determine whether or not you can predict
that because that's one way of testing
whether or not the phenomena that you've
derived say from your statistical
analysis,
both in the case of fluid intelligence
or intelligence more broadly.
And in the case of the big five actually
has the capacity to manifest itself in a
meaningful way in the world outside of
inside the lab.
That's one domain of potential
validation,
but then outside the lab as well.
And so what we're going to do today is
to look at the factors that determine
performance in the real world.
And so you might think,
well,
what are some important real world
outcomes on which performance might
vary?
And we're going to stick to those that
are rather obvious today.
We talked about creative achievement
already for example,
but you could think of creative
achievement,
entrepreneurial achievement,
those actually clumped together.
They're part of the same phenomena.
You think about academic achievement and
you could think about success in the
workplace and then those can be
subdivided because success in the
workplace for example,
needs to be analyzed in terms of
success.
Say at simple jobs in success at complex
jobs you'd like.
There's different ways of fractioning
fractionating a phenomena to increase
your capacity,
to understand it and to measure it and
then to predict it.
But those are rough domains where
there's self evident individual
differences.
And where the capacity to predict
performance would at least be of some
utility,
a performance in the workplace.
This is an interesting one.
Performance in the workplace is a tricky
measure.
A tricky issue.
I've been working on performance
prediction tests for a long time because
I was interested in,
because I'm a clinical psychologist and
because I have a practical side,
I'm often interested in what the utility
of psychological measurements might be
outside the lab.
It's interesting to consider that from
an ethical perspective too.
So if you're hiring people,
you have
to conundrums that lay themselves in
front of you and one is the ethical
necessity to give each person a fair
chance.
And the other is the ethical necessity
to place the proper person in the proper
position.
And you might say,
well you could do that randomly and like
there are countries in Europe for
example,
that have a quasi random approach to the
selection of university students.
So Holland just like that,
they have a pretty open admission
policy.
Now,
what that means is that everyone has a
chance to go to college,
but the downside of it is that the
failure rate in the first year,
for example,
is extraordinarily high.
Now you might say that's a perfectly
reasonable price to pay for the open
admission and for the opportunity to
give everyone a chance,
but you could also say,
well,
that's a hell of a waste of time for the
people who go into the first year of
college or university and fail.
It's not a pleasant experience for them.
It's a very expensive in terms of time
and resources and perhaps it would have
been better for them and for broader
society had.
They'd been able to determine beforehand
whether they had two sets of qualities
that were necessary to increase the
probability of success.
Because if I could tell you,
well,
you know,
you have a 80 percent chance of success
in this domain and only a 20 percent
chance in this domain.
You still might want to take the risk in
the 20 percent success domain.
But you might also think,
well,
I might as well go off and function
where my particular combination of
proclivities has the best opportunity to
manifest itself.
And,
and because why not position yourself
for success rather than failure?
Now,
I'm not saying that the ethical
conundrum between those two alternatives
is something that's easy to,
uh,
what would you say an easy thing to map
your way through.
It's by no means an easy way to map your
way through because there are strong
arguments to be had on both sides of the
equation,
so,
but
there's still the scientific question
that remains,
which is to what degree can you
accurately predict people's performance
and to what degree does that reflect
positively or negatively on your
psychological concepts?
And then there's the actual practical
utility of potentially offering to
schools,
to universities and to workplaces in
general the probability of selecting
people with an above average chance of
succeeding.
It's even more complicated.
Say if you're selecting not so much
entry level employees in a company
because maybe you tell yourself they are
more towards the possibility of bringing
more people in and letting them fail or
succeed in the job,
but let's say you're replacing a
management team at a medium to large
size corporation.
You know if you bring in managers that
are in competent,
not only are they going to fail,
which is obviously not very good for
them,
and the failure rate among managers is
very high.
It exceeds.
It exceeds 65.
I figure,
I think it's 65 percent of managers.
I believe that's correct.
Add zero or negative net value to the
companies.
It's something like that.
The failure rate in managerial positions
is overwhelming and the problem with
bringing someone into a managerial or an
executive position even worse,
who isn't competent to play that role is
that they can wipe out the careers of
everyone that they're supervising.
And in the case of say,
large companies,
they can bring the whole damn company
down and so it's not like the the,
the ethic of people deserve an equal
chance,
let's say,
to fail and succeed isn't a very
practical ethic.
When you're putting someone in a high
demand position where the consequences
of failure are can be overwhelming,
not only for that person but for all the
people that they happen to be whose
destiny they happen to be involved in
determining.
And so then you might say,
if you could come up with a selection
process that would increase the
probability of hiring and above average
manager from 50 slash 50 to 60 slash 40
or 70 slash 30.
Maybe you're actually ethically
compelled to use that.
And in fact,
by law,
this is particularly the case in the
United States.
You're required by law to use the most
effective,
valid,
reliable and nondiscriminatory selection
process that currently exists in order
to select your employees.
And one of the things that's going to
happen to employers in the next 10 years
is they're going to get a very nasty
shock for using interviews.
Because the data on unstructured
interviews indicates quite clearly that
a,
that they're discriminatory,
partly because they they,
for example,
if you're tall and assertive and good
looking and charming,
then you're much more likely to do well
in an interview,
but that doesn't necessarily have any
bearing whatsoever on the probability
that you'll succeed in the position and
so and not only that,
the predictive validity of unstructured
interviews is very low.
It's about point one,
two.
It's something like that which means
that if you just pick people randomly
for success or failure,
let's say you'd have a 50 slash 50
chance of predicting whether someone was
going to be a success or a failure.
It's just a coin toss and then if you
used an unstructured interview,
you'd get that up to 56,
44,
which is slightly better,
but it's by no means it's not even close
to the accuracy that you could get.
For example,
if you just use the standard test of
conscientiousness,
which would give you a correlation of
about point two five with with say
managerial with managerial productivity
and there's this interesting.
This is an interesting thing to know.
It's called the binomial effect size,
display effect size is the magnitude of
an effect,
right,
and and it's not an easy thing to get a
handle on all that you really need to,
if you're going to be a psychologist,
because in any study there is an effect
size indicator correlation off often or
an r squared,
which is the correlation squared or a
Cohen's d,
which has the effect size expressed in
standard deviation.
So something like that,
but you kind of have to understand that
at a basic level to understand what
statistics actually do.
And there's this phenomena called the
binomial effect size display that can
help you understand in an embodied sense
what the magnitude of a correlation
means.
So here's how it works.
Imagine that you have a predictor of
point two zero.
So the correlation is r equals point two
zero between phenomena.
One will say conscientiousness and
phenomena,
two,
workplace performance point two,
zero correlation.
The question might be,
well,
how much?
How much would you improve your
predictive capacity over chance levels
if you applied that predictor?
And the answer is that the ar is the
difference between the odds ratio.
So let me explain that.
So point five,
zero point five zero.
If you subtract one from the other,
you get zero.
So the predictive validity of selection
by chance is zero point five,
zero minus point five,
zero equals zero.
That's the predictive validity of
chance.
If you have a predictor of point two
zero,
which is approximately,
that's sort of the low end estimate for
conscientiousness,
then that would change your odds ratio
from point five,
zero point five zero,
right?
Random two,
point six,
zero point four zero because point six
zero minus point four,
zero point two zero.
And so the correlation coefficient turns
out to be the difference between the
odds between the odds.
So and so it gives you a quick rule of
thumb.
So for example,
so if you have a point two zero
predictor that gives you 60 slash 40,
if you have a point three zero
predictor,
that gives you 60 5:35 because point
six,
five minus point three five is point
three zero.
And if you have a point six predictor,
which is really up on the high end,
right,
you're really starting to push your
limits of statistical predict prediction
validity at that point.
That gives you a point eight zero minus
point two zero.
And so what you've done,
if you use a predictive of a predictor
that has a correlation Coefficient of
point six zero,
which you could get,
for example,
if you took conscientiousness and
combined that with a good test of Iq for
predicting complex jobs,
you might be able to get up to point six
that moves your odds ratio of selecting
an above average person for the position
from point five,
zero point five,
zero two point eight,
zero point two zero.
So it cuts your failure rate by more
than half,
right?
Brings it down from point five,
zero.
Point two zero,
because point eight,
zero minus point two,
zero point six zero.
So that's a really good thing to know.
That's called the binomial effect size
display.
It's really good thing to have in your
mind.
It's very simple.
It's just a,
it's just subtraction and it gives you
some sense of the power of,
of,
of statistical prediction.
Now the question might be,
well,
let's say you had a predictor of point
two zero conscientiousness.
You might say,
well,
if you square,
they are.
That gives you four percent of the
variance.
Who the hell cares for percent of the
variance?
You've left 95 percent of the
variability between people in terms of
their performance unexplained.
You might say,
well,
why even bother?
Well,
the answer to that question is how much
difference in productive output is there
between people?
Because if there's a tremendous degree
of productive,
of difference in productive output
between people than increasing your
ability to predict someone's
performance,
even by some relatively small increment
might have massive economic utility.
If let's say the top 10 percent of your
people are 50 times as productive as the
bottom 10 percent of your people than
shifting your ability to predict up so
that you have more of those extremely
high performing people or less of the
extremely low performing people might
more than payoff might more than pay for
itself.
From an economic perspective,
even though your prediction,
your predictor isn't,
doesn't have that massive amount of
power when that actually happens to be
the case.
So back in 1968,
there was a guy named Walter Michelle.
He had reviewed,
he's a social psychologist.
He reviewed the personality literature
up to that point and concluded that the
typical personality measure only
predicted the typical performance
measure at about point two and that's
actually remained relatively stable.
I would say it's a little higher than
that.
It's probably point two five,
especially if you do things like correct
for measurement,
error and so forth.
And what Michelle said was,
because it's only point two five,
let's say you square that,
that's five percent of the variants.
You leave 95 percent of the phenomena
unexplained.
You might as well not even bother
measuring personality and so that
actually killed the field of personality
from a psychometric perspective for
about 25 years.
Really until about the early 19 nineties
when people woke up and thought,
wait a minute,
what are the typical effect sizes in
other domains of prediction?
And then they found out that,
well,
the point two zero correlation that was
typical of personality prediction was
actually pretty damn good by social
sciences or health sciences standards,
like it doesn't sound good when you just
think about it as an absolute measure
because it leaves 95 percent of the
phenomena unexplained,
but when you compare it to other things
that people consider of reasonable
magnitude than it turns out that
personality psychologists are doing just
fine.
And then also in the 19 nineties,
and I'll show you some of this,
the economic calculations done and the
so one of the calculations would be well
imagine that you have maybe it took 20
companies and you did it a distribution
of the productivity of their employees.
It's hard thing to do because you have
to measure their productivity.
So how the hell do you do that?
Right?
With salespeople,
you can measure sales.
That's pretty straightforward.
With lawyers,
you can measure hours billed.
Like there are some,
there are some occupations where the
performance measure is sort of built
into the job.
But if you're a manager in the mid level
of a large corporation,
how the hell can you tell how productive
you are?
It's so there's a measurement problem on
the productivity measurement and as well
as the performance prediction and and
it's.
It's a very intractable problem and the
way that people often do that is by
saying,
well,
let's say you're a manager in the mid
level of a corporation.
How do we determine how productive we
are?
You are,
while we might ask you to compare your,
your work productivity with your peers,
maybe construct up a questionnaire
asking about your efficient use of time
and so forth,
and then we might get your peers to do
the same thing to you.
We might get your supervisors to do the
same thing to you and we might get your,
your subordinates to do the same thing
to you and then aggregate across all
those measures and infer that that
aggregate opinion actually constitutes a
valid measure of productivity.
You actually don't know,
right?
Because that assumes that what you're
doing,
that your peers and your supervisors and
so forth.
Our rating is actually related in some
positive manner to the bottom line of
the company and you actually don't.
You actually can't figure that out.
This is actually,
I think why,
why large companies start to become
unstable is because if there's enough
layers between the operations of the
people in the tiers of the corporation
and the real outcome measure,
which is basically profit because that's
what we've got.
Then the relationship between your
activity as a manager and the
productivity of the company starts to
become increasingly blurred and that
might mean that you're working as hard
as you can on something that's actually
going to cost the company money so you
would actually be much more productive
from a profit perspective if you just
didn't go to work at all and that that
happens a lot in large corporations
because you'd never know,
especially if there's a lot of steps
that have to be undertaken in a process
before you can test the product in the
market.
You have no idea if you're wasting time
and resources.
You just can't tell.
So the performance measurement issue is
a very,
very complicated one.
We haven't talked about it that much,
but I gave you a kind of a brief
overview of it.
Now what you really want to do is have
multiple sources of information about
performance and aggregate across them
and if you can use real world measures
that are tied to two income generation,
so much the better because you have to
use something as your gold standard,
right?
You have to say at some point while
we're going to define this as reality,
when it comes to performance and in a
free market economy,
roughly what you do there is you say
that what profit is the proxy for
productivity and that isn't the same
thing saying is that it isn't the same
thing as saying that profit is
productivity.
That's not the same thing.
It's saying that at some point you have
to decide what you're going to accept as
a measure of productivity because
otherwise there's no point in even
talking about it and you can't just not
talk about productivity if you're
running an organization because the
organization doesn't exist unless it
produces something that will keep it
going and generally that happens to be
money.
So anyways,
it's quite,
it's very complicated.
All of this.
I was also curious about because,
because I'm curious,
I guess is to find out what would happen
if I took a measure that was derived in
the lab and then try to launch it out in
a,
in the actual real world environment,
tried to market and sell it and now that
was very informative because I presume
that we develop tests,
which I'll talk to you about.
There were actually pretty good at
predicting performance,
managerial performance for example,
administrative performance.
We got ours have upwards of point six
which is really bloody impressive.
So we could,
we could tell employers,
look,
if you use our tests,
we can increase the probability that
you'll hire an above average employee
from 50 slash 50 to 80 20 and the
economic benefit of that will be
staggering.
Staggering.
And,
and I'll show you the calculations that
enabled that sort of,
that sort of prediction to be made.
And you might think,
well and this is what you do think.
If you're naive about producing
something of value,
you might think,
well,
if you can produce something that's of
self evident,
economic value selling,
it will be a snap and that is so wrong,
you just cannot believe it.
So one of the things we found,
which was really mind boggling to me was
that you could make a case that the
probability that a company will use a
test that predicts performance,
the pro,
the probability that they will use the
test is inversely related to the
accuracy of the test,
which basically means that the less
accurate tests are easier to sell and
you think,
well,
why the hell would that be?
Why?
And the how in the world would it
possibly be that corporations would
rather buy tests that don't work than
tests that do work and that that is what
they do because really what they do by
is the Meyer's breaks,
right?
That sells about a million units a year
and the Myers Briggs has zero predictive
utility with regards to performance
prediction.
So why do people use it?
Oh,
here's one reason it doesn't hurt
anybody's feelings.
Everybody wins,
right?
And so then you think,
well,
do corporations really care whether or
not everybody wins when they're being
tested?
And the answer to that is yes,
much more often than you would think so.
So we hit all sorts of barriers.
That was one.
The problem with tests that work is that
most of the people who take them don't
do very well on them.
And then the other problem is that
people,
people aren't good at statistical
reasoning at all.
They're really,
really bad at it.
And so for example,
they don't know the difference between a
percentage and a percentile.
So a percentage is if you get 40 percent
on a test,
it means you've got 40 percent of the
questions,
right?
If you,
if you are at the 40th percentile in the
distribution of test scores,
it means that you perform better than 40
percent of the people.
That's actually not too bad.
Right?
But you'll think,
no,
that's not 40 percentile,
that's 40 percent.
And then you'll think that you failed.
And so one of the things we found for
example,
was that when we were,
when we were marketing the tests to mid
level managers who had some say at least
on whether or not they would be used,
the first thing they would say as well,
I want to do the test.
And the thing you say about that is no
you don't because this is derived
statistically,
you can't validate the test on the basis
of your opinion about its applicability
in your case,
but you can't have that conversation
that isn't going to go anywhere because
they say,
well,
I'd never give a test to my
employees that I hadn't taken myself.
It's like,
okay.
So then you think,
well you're a typical manager,
you're going to score at the 50th
percentile.
You are not going to be happy about that
because you want a score at the 90th
percentile because you confuse
percentiles and percentages.
And also because you don't notice that
if you're doing better than 50 percent
of the managers.
That's actually pretty damn good
question.
Yeah,
that's a good lead.
I'll,
I'll answer that as I go through this.
Okay.
So,
so that was often at a dead started
right there.
And then the other thing we'd find this
was cool to have horrible but cool.
So imagine a large corporation and you
go in and you try to make a sales pitch
to someone and maybe they're in hr and
they say,
and you say to them,
look,
you could use these tests if you use it
for 100.
People will increase your bottom line by
$2,000,000 a year.
You think people would be jumping up and
down about that.
And they say,
well how much does it cost?
And we say,
well it doesn't matter because the cost
to benefit ratio is what you should care
about,
not the cost.
Because they would want it say for $9 a
test.
It was like,
no,
if you do this for each and I'll show
you the mathematics and a bit.
Each person that you select with this
test will bring $20,000 of extra value
to your company.
You're not getting that for $9.
And then they say,
well wait a minute.
We have a budget for testing that's
limited to $9 a test and they say,
well,
it's going to produce $30,000 a year in
revenue.
They say,
well that revenue goes to another branch
of the company and we won't get any
credit for it.
We'll just get punished because we've
exceeded our budget,
our budget for selection.
I thought,
Oh yeah,
I never,
never,
never expected that to come up as an
obstacle so you know,
so we had very well designed products.
They also talk about 90 minutes because
we,
we started with a full scale
neuropsychological assessment,
so we took tests of dorsolateral
prefrontal cortical ability which had
before that been administered by neuro
psychologists and we computerized and we
did that back in 1993.
So it was among the first attempts to do
this sort of thing and then we had a 90
minute test battery that also assessed
the big five and then you could give
that to employees and you know,
you could,
you could produce this 80 slash 20
differential that I described and well
then we found out what that test was too
long.
It's like,
well,
what do you mean you're going to gain
$30,000 a year per employee if you use
this test?
It's like,
no,
people don't want to be tested that log.
It's like,
okay,
so you want an accurate test that
doesn't discriminate against anybody.
That makes everyone feel good.
That's dirt cheap and that doesn't take
any time at all.
It's like,
well,
it took us about 15 years to build one
of those after we had built the original
thing that actually worked and so even
then the the,
the process of trying to introduce it
into the workplace was almost
impossible.
The other thing you find if you're
trying to sell the large companies,
this is this is worth knowing,
is that it's great if you can sell to a
large company because it's a large
company man and so you.
The potential for the sale is
astronomical,
but large companies are so slow you
cannot believe it,
and so it might take you three years.
First of all,
you have to find who you should talk to.
That's impossible because they all the
people that you can talk to have no
decision making power whatsoever,
so all you do is waste your time talking
to them and they'll talk to you.
They'll have meetings with you,
but it won't matter because they don't
have any decision making power and then
you can't get access to people who have
the decision making power because they
don't let you have access to them.
And so that's a huge problem and even
figuring them out is a huge problem.
And even figuring out that those are the
people that you need to talk to is a
huge problem.
So that might take you five years just
to get it through your head that,
that you're wasting your time.
Ninety five percent of the time talking
to the wrong people.
And so then the next thing that happens,
this is really,
this is really comical.
So let's say you do make some headway.
It takes you three bloody years.
You've,
you've made a relationship with the
person,
they're ready to launch it.
Then they have to market it internally
and that takes them a year because they
have to convince everybody to get
onboard and then the corporation
reshuffles and the person that you're
dealing with disappears.
It's like that happened to us.
We were marketing to a very large
company.
We would go all the way up to the CEO
and ready to with this was with the
future authoring program and we were
ready to launch the damn product.
It took us a huge amount of time to get
through all the layers and just the week
that we were going to launch it,
the CEO resigned and the company stock
crashed and that was the end of that.
Bang and and large companies are like
that.
Like they're extremely slow and the
typical duration that a person lasts in
a given position,
and this is something to consider with
regards to your careers is both for
years.
So you'll occupy the position you're in
for about four years and then while
you'll either fail out,
you'll move laterally or you'll move up.
And so it's a three year sales cycle
minimum,
and that's interweaved with the
possibility that whoever you're talking
to is just going to disappear.
It's so.
And then if you small cell to small
companies,
well they're faster,
but they don't have any money.
So that's not very helpful.
So it's extraordinarily difficult even
if you produce something of high value
and that you have proof that the thing
exists,
it's extraordinarily difficult to sell
it.
And so here's another thing to think
about.
No,
I think I've mentioned this to you
before.
If you write a book which is virtually
impossible,
and then get a publisher,
which is virtually impossible,
you probably have a rejection rate of 99
percent.
So then if you do,
if you do manage to publish the book
with a reasonable publisher,
which you won't because it's impossible,
then you get eight percent royalties.
That's it.
So 92 percent of your labor goes to the
sales,
marketing and distribution end of
things.
And so it's just.
So it's very,
very difficult to generate capital as an
entrepreneur.
And there's innumerable impediments.
One of the things that people do,
and this is something for those of you
who might be entrepreneurially minded,
here's another thing that you have to
understand is that you can't really
create a product and then launch it
because first of all,
you don't know how to do that.
You might know how to create the
product,
but you do not know how to market or
sell it.
You don't know how to advertise it.
You don't know how to communicate about
it.
You don't know how to ship it like
there's all sorts of things you just
don't know,
but worse is you don't know if people
will use it and so what companies do
that,
jen,
that roll out new products on a
relatively continual basis do is they
don't develop the product and then go
sell it.
They continually communicate with their
customers about what product the
customer is willing to buy next and then
they develop that and so you have to
have your market identified and then you
have to be in continual communication
with the market.
Well,
you develop the product.
It's not.
I built a better mouse trap and the
world comes marching to my door.
That isn't how it works is that you got
to find out if someone wants to buy your
stupid thing and then the next thing is
is that even if you have a great thing,
you're going to go talk to people and
they have 50 great things that they
might buy and they're all great,
but they're not going to buy all 50.
They might buy one maybe and maybe
they'll buy it this week,
but probably they'll buy it in six
months and they're not going to buy any
of them no matter how great.
Unless they're on fire and you're
selling water because they're so busy
already,
right?
They're so overwhelmed and preoccupied
by their jobs that if you come in and
you say,
well,
here,
this is going to increase your
efficiency by 20 percent and here's the
three weeks.
You'd have to spend doing that,
and then the payoff would come in the
next years.
They'll say,
yeah,
we'll all do that as soon as I have
time,
and as soon as I have,
time is never.
So if they're on fire and you have
water,
you can sell it to them,
but that's all because otherwise it's a
no goal.
So those are all things that,
that are worthwhile knowing because
they're very hard to learn.
And so and very comically,
I mean,
if you would've told me when I first
started developing these tests that one
of the reasons corporations wouldn't buy
them because they worked that I would
have just thought really.
I mean,
come on.
Really?
That's really the reason.
It's like,
yeah,
that's the reason God.
So very,
very,
very problematic.
And then they already have their
processes in place and they're
entrenched.
And then then the next problem is,
you know,
you haven't got any customers.
I think I told you that before,
you don't have any customers and you
show them the statistics,
but they can understand this statistics
and they also have 200 other people
selling them things and 50 of them are
crooks.
So they're just lying about what they're
doing.
They can't tell the difference between
the liars and the people who were
telling the truth.
And so they can't and they can't
understand the statistics for themselves
and they can't verify them anyways.
So what they ask you is who else is
using it?
And if the answer is,
well everybody,
then you don't even have to do the sale
because you're already rich.
And if the answer is nobody,
then they are going to say,
well,
why is nobody using this?
You say,
well,
it's the hottest thing that's come along
and they think,
well,
I'm not going to be the sucker who gets
painted red dead fired because this
failed that they do not think this might
make me succeed.
People do not about whether or not they
succeed.
They care about whether or not they
fail.
And so that's another thing is that if
you're marketing something and you can
say,
this will stop you from being identified
as a failure than people might be happy
about that.
But if you say,
this will really help you succeed.
It's like,
yeah,
no,
I don't want to succeed.
I just don't want to fail.
I just want to be invisible and be left
alone.
And if you're looking for people's
fundamental motivation,
that's it.
It's they want to be invisible and they
want to be left alone.
I tell you,
the Zebra story [inaudible] you,
any of you know that story.
Okay,
I'll,
I'll tell you,
this is ebro story.
Tell it,
stop me if I've told it to you before.
This tells you everything you need to
know about human beings.
So it's weird.
It's worth.
It's worth knowing.
Okay?
So zebras have stripes and people say,
well,
that's for camouflage.
And then you think about that for two
seconds and you think that's a really
stupid theory because lions are
camouflaged and they're like golden,
like the grass and zebras are black and
white.
So you can see a zebra five miles away.
It's like there's a zebra,
it's black and white.
So the whole camouflage thing that's
just not working out so well as a
hypothesis.
Okay?
So bylaw biologists go and they decided
to take a look at some zebras and so
they're looking at zebra at on the herd
because there's no zebra,
right?
Just like there's no fish.
There are schools of fish and there are
herds of zebras.
There isn't a fish.
This is why I think the cod aren't
coming back.
There are no cod.
There are massive hundred mile long
schools have cod,
10 stories deep,
20 million years old.
You wipe out the school.
You don't just get to throw a quad in
the water and say,
well,
you know,
off you go.
It's like,
well,
where's my city?
It's like launching you in the middle of
a field.
It's like,
well,
go out there and reproduce.
It's like,
no,
that's not gonna happen.
You know,
so without the school that there's no
cod and you can't just introduce a whole
school of cod because you don't have a
whole school of cod.
So you know,
maybe the cod are never coming back and
zebras are the same thing.
There's not a zebra,
there's zebras and so you're looking at
the zebras trying to study as zebra and
you look at the Zebra and you make some
notes and you look up and you think,
oh Christ.
Which zebra was I looking at?
And the answer to that is you don't know
because the,
the camouflage is against the herd and
the black and white stripes.
There's a variety of reasons for this.
Stripes flies also seem not to like the
stripes,
but you know,
usually people,
things evolve for multiple reasons.
But anyways,
it's very difficult to parse out a zebra
against the herd.
You look down,
you look up,
it's like,
oh,
I'll hold those damn zebras look the
same.
Yes,
the camouflage is effective,
but it's against the herd.
All right?
So then you think,
well we better identify a zebra so we
can see what he's up to.
So then you take your jeep and a can of
red paint and a stick with a rag on the
end of it.
And you drive up to the zebras and you
paint their haunch.
Read that a little bit,
put a nice red dot on their haunch or
maybe clipped the rear with a clip.
And then you know,
you stand back and you think,
Hey,
I'm pretty,
now I'm going to watch that zebra.
So what do you think happens to the
Zebra?
The lions kill it.
Right?
Right,
right,
because lions,
they're smart,
right?
Hunter hunting animals are smart,
but they have to identify a zebra before
they can organize their hunt.
They can't just hunt the whole herd.
They have to pick out a zebra and so
maybe it's like a zebra that's got a
sore hip or something.
And so you think,
well,
nature's kind.
It just takes the week.
It's though no zebra or lions,
like really healthy delicious zebras,
but they look like all the other
healthy,
delicious zebras so they can't get a
beat on them.
But if there are small and just born or
if they're limping or there's something
that identifies them,
then the lions can pick them out and
then they do pick them out.
And so the rule for human beings is keep
your damn stripes on so the lions don't
get you.
And I'm telling you,
man,
if you want to remember one thing from
my class about human motivation,
that's a good thing to learn.
People camouflage themselves against the
herd and they like to be in the middle
of the herd,
which is what fish do.
By the way,
if you have a big school of fish,
the smart,
healthy,
large fish are in the middle of the
school because you know what you call a
fish on the outside of the school bait,
right?
So that's what people are doing there
are trying to move into the middle of
the herd all the time and the herd moves
around or the school moves around and
people are going,
well,
I'm in the middle,
I'm staying in the middle here,
so I've got this protective ring of
people around me so the predators don't
pick me out and do me in.
So okay,
so that's part of the reason why I said,
well,
you can't sell something to someone for
success because you're thinking,
well,
people are aiming at success.
Don't,
don't be thinking that.
It's not by any means necessarily true
trait.
Neuroticism is a potential most powerful
motivator and trait.
Neuroticism is let's not be too
threatened or hurt,
right?
That's the negative emotion system.
And the negative emotion system is a
killer source of motivation.
You know,
you also see that there are scales of
wellbeing that have been designed mostly
by social psychologists,
which means they're very bad scales most
of the time because their psychometric
capacity is absurdly low,
generally speaking,
so what you find with scales of
wellbeing sometimes they're talked about
as scales of happiness even is that
people aren't after happiness
thereafter,
not hurting.
It's not so they don't want to be
extroverted and enthusiastic,
right and and bubbly and full of smiles
and laughter.
That isn't what they mean by I want to
be happy.
What they mean is I don't want to be
anxious or in pain,
and so wellbeing scales tend to be
something like
neuroticism,
sorry,
emotional stability plus extroversion,
but the big loading is on emotional
stability.
The reverse of neuroticism.
You want to avoid suffering.
You don't want to be happy.
You want to avoid suffering,
and one way to avoid suffering is not to
let the Lions Gnaw on you,
and one way of doing that is to stay in
the middle of the damn hurt and so and
like,
I'm not being a smart Alec about this.
I understand why people do that.
There's real danger to being visible.
There's real danger in being visible.
Now.
You might be successful if you're
visible,
but you also might be dead.
So okay,
so now there's a number of things to
consider if you're thinking about
performance prediction and one of them
is to what degree do people vary in
terms of their performance capacity and
you might say,
well,
there's very little performance
variability,
or you might say there's a tremendous
amount of performance variability,
or you might say there's an absurd
amount of performance variability and it
turns out that the claim that there's an
absurd amount of performance variability
is the proper claim.
Iq is normally distributed,
so is conscientiousness,
but productivity is distributed along
the prieto distribution and I'll show
you why and that follows a law called
price's law from someone named Derek to
solar price who was studying scientific
productivity in the early 19 sixties.
And what he showed was that a
vanishingly small proportion of the
scientists operating in a given
scientific domain produced half the
output.
And so what you see and what's happening
is that to do really well at a given
productive task,
which would also include generating
money as as a proxy for,
for,
for creative productivity,
is that you have to be a bunch of
things,
have to go your way simultaneously.
So maybe you have to be really,
really smart.
You have to be really,
really lucky.
You have to be really healthy,
you have to be really energetic,
you have to be really conscientious,
you have to be in the right time at the
right place,
and maybe you also have to have the
right social network,
right?
So it's a lot of things and each of
those are small probability there.
Each of those are small probabilities.
And then if you multiply the small
probabilities together,
you get an extraordinarily tiny
probability and you have to have all
those things functioning before you're
going to end out on the,
on the,
on the extreme end of the productivity
distribution.
But if you do end up there,
then you produce almost all of
everything.
So it's a tiny number of people that
produce almost all of everything.
That's price's law and technically it
is,
and I mentioned this to you before,
it's the square root law.
The square root of the number of people
in a productive domain produce half the
output,
right?
So if you have 10 employees,
three of them produce half the output.
If you have 100,
10 of them produce half the output.
If you have 10,000,
100 of them produce half the productive
output,
and so what that also means is that
because there's massive variability in
performance,
you don't have to shift your ability to
predict performance very,
very,
very much up towards being better at it
to gain substantially on the positive
side because there's so much difference
in productivity and that actually
happens to be also a function of the
complexity of the job.
If the job is simple,
which is means you can.
This job has 10 rules,
maybe that's a janitorial job.
Let's say you do,
it takes a little while to learn it,
but once you've learned it,
you basically do the same thing all the
time.
There's not a lot of performance
variability in those jobs and most of
that would be not by conscientiousness
and also to some by neuroticism because
the higher people who are higher in
neuroticism would be more likely to miss
work,
but,
but general cognitive ability for
example,
is not a good predictor at all.
It'll predict how fast you learn the
tasks initially,
but not how well you perform the test,
but if the task to you're doing are
shifting constantly,
so your responsibilities change or
you're in a creative job where you're
constantly solving new problems.
So those are kind of the same thing.
Then Iq,
as the complexity of the job increases,
the predictive utility of Iq increases,
which is only to say that smarter people
can handle complex situations faster.
So that's doesn't seem like a
particularly radical claim.
So price's law dictates that there's
massive individual productivity
differences between people.
So increasing your predictive,
your capacity for predicting performance
even by small increments,
has a huge economic consequence.
That was established in the 19 nineties.
The equations were first developed in
the 19 nineties and that's part of the
reason that I started working on
performance prediction tests because I
read the economics and I thought,
oh my God,
you can produce a test that costs $30
times.
Say Baby,
you have 50 applicants for the position,
$1,500 to administer,
and it'll produce an increments of
something like 30 percent of salary
permanently for the person that you put
in a position.
So let's say you hire a $75,000 employee
and it increases their productivity by
30 percent,
so we'll say roughly $25,000,
you'll get a $25,000 return on a $1,500
investment every single year.
That person occupies the position on
average,
that's four years.
That's $100,000 payoff for your $1,500
investment.
I read that.
I thought,
oh,
that'll be easy to sell.
It's like wrong.
Wrong.
Even though the economic payoff was so
massive,
I told you the other impediments that
did emerge,
but the,
the arithmetic or the capacity to
produce these calculations was
established in the 19 nineties and I'll
show you the equations in a bit here.
Okay,
so we already talked about what a normal
distribution looks like.
That's the red line and a normal
distribution emerges as a consequence of
chance processes.
So we'll take a look at those here.
Hopefully this will work.
Look at that.
So there's your corporate advertisement
for the day,
but it's not often you see a heroic,
normal distribution,
but they're.
There you go.
So,
so,
so what you see is that you get a
pattern output as a consequence of
chance processes and so where you
happened to be on the distribution for
all of the traits that we've described
as a consequence of innumerable chance,
genetic genetic and cultural processes.
But a lot of them are a lot more than
people like to admit her genetic.
I mean you can make people stupid or
with the environment,
but it's not that easy to make them
smarter.
So because it's what I think about it,
right,
it's way easier to make something worse
than it is to make something better,
and so even if you take everyone and you
give them optimal access to information
and say optimal nutrition,
which pretty much everybody's in that
position now,
at least in so far as we can manage it,
you're going to get massive genetic
differences in such things as
conscientiousness or extroversion or
intelligence as you would.
In fact,
as you flatten out the sociocultural
environment,
say you take everybody and you provide
them with optimal nutrition and optimal
access to information,
which you've pretty much done by the way
with a computer,
right?
Because how are you going to give
someone more access to information than
to give them a web enabled computer?
That's it,
right?
There's.
There's just no better.
It's an infinite library.
You can learn anything with it.
So we're done.
We've equalized the education landscape
roughly speaking and then nutritionally.
Well,
you know,
yeah,
some people eat badly and some people
eat better,
but the option to eat well is basically
open to at least everybody in North
America.
Roughly speaking,
you've wiped out the social socio
cultural variation.
You might think,
well,
that equalizes people.
It's wrong.
All it does is reduce the variability to
the remaining biological differences.
You maximize the genetic variability by
minimizing the socio variability,
right?
Very important thing to understand.
This is why the gender differences
between personality between men and
women are largest in the Scandinavian
countries.
Tens of thousands of people have been
assessed along these dimensions.
We know that we know the data that have
come in are clear.
The biggest differences between men and
women in the in terms of personality and
in terms of interest are in the
Scandinavian countries.
Why wiped out sociocultural variation?
All you've got left is biological
differences,
so,
so well.
You can draw your own conclusions from
that.
It's unfortunate and fortunate at the
same time.
All right,
so here's a parade distribution.
This is the distribution.
Remember I showed you with the creative
achievement questionnaire that almost
everybody stacked up at zero,
people have zero creative output,
the median person has zero lifetime
creative output and then there's a tiny
proportion that are way the hell out on
the right hand end of the distribution,
right?
Those are the people have who have
everything is cycling forward for them
and as they get more well known,
of course they get more opportunities as
well.
Con,
cut.
Person's very conscientious.
So I just,
I'll just run this simulation for you.
Okay?
And this shows you why the distribution
emerges.
Now you have to watch this quickly
because it's a fairly fast animation.
So here's what happens.
Everybody starts out with $10.
There's a thousand people playing the
game.
Everybody starts out with $10.
We have a dollar,
you have a dollar.
I flip a coin.
If I get heads,
you give me a dollar.
If I get tails,
I give you a daughter.
We go around and we trade with everyone.
Okay?
So the first thing that happens when
people start to trade is this normal
distribution develops,
right?
Because some people lose and some people
when it's just like the Golden Board
that I showed you,
okay,
so you keep playing.
People start to stack up at zero watch
because they lose 10 times in a row,
Bang,
they're done.
The bottom graph is a graph of the
entropy of the distribution,
which increases as the game continues
because at the beginning it's maximally
ordered,
right?
Everybody has exactly the same amount.
Now it's being distributed.
Same equations apply to the distribution
of gas into a vacuum.
Well,
what happens now,
someone you know,
there are people out there at the,
at the $50 range or at the $60 range,
at the $70 range.
You keep playing it.
Well eventually what happens if you play
it right to its conclusion is that one
person ends up with all the money,
so that's to those who have everything
more will be given from those who have
nothing.
Everything will be taken.
That's the law of economic productivity.
It's called Matthew is the matthew
principle and it's actually an economic
principle that was derived from a saying
in the New Testament.
I'll tell you some more about this on
Tuesday because I didn't get through all
of it and I want to.
I want to finish up the performance
prediction lecture and show you a couple
of things.
I didn't get to show you
the last time that we talked and then I
want to do the closing lecture since
we're done today,
so we'll start with the performance
prediction and so I've been thinking
more about this prieto distribution
issue because it's a really big deal and
it's difficult.
It's still difficult for me to
understand and see.
I didn't really learn about this about
10 years ago,
which is quite a shock to me because
it's such a fundamental phenomenon that
it seems to me that it would have been
addressed in my training somewhere along
the way and so
and so.
I'm still thinking it through what it
means exactly.
Now,
here's,
here's an interesting thing.
You know,
that Iq is normally distributed and it's
a good predictor of long term
performance and conscientiousness is
normally distributed and it's a good
predictor of longterm performance and an
openness is also normally distributed
and it's a good predictor of creative
behavior,
but creative output is not normally
distributed.
It's distributed in this weird prieto
distribution that that's indexed here.
And I showed you that with the creative
achievement questionnaire most
specifically because that provides a
really concrete example of it.
Um,
so it looks like the capacity to think
creatively might be normally
distributed.
That would be openness say and
intelligence.
But the consequence of that turns into
this strange prieto distribution.
And the credo distribution with regards
to creative achievement was best.
The catastrophe of it in some senses
best indexed by the fact that if I
remember correctly,
70 percent of people who complete the
creative achievement questionnaire,
which indexes lifetime creativity score
zero.
So zero is a strange number.
You know,
zero isn't like other numbers.
And the part of the reason for that is
that it's difficult to do anything with
nothing.
So you know,
if you,
if you buy a stock and the and the price
sinks to like two cents a stock,
you're still alive.
But if the price sinks to zero,
you're done.
Right?
That's it.
The game's over.
And that's the thing about zero when you
hit zero or maybe when you're at zero,
the game is over.
And when,
when,
when we were attempting to market,
for example,
the tests that we had designed to
predict performance in companies,
one of the big obstacles to begin with
was having zero customers and zero
customers is really the wrong number of
customers to have.
And there's a big difference between
zero customers then one customer,
right?
Because then you're in the game.
But.
And so there's these weird barriers to
moving forward in life.
And you see this,
there's a poverty trap that's sort of
like this too.
Like if you're,
if you're so broke that you can't keep
up with paying your bills.
It's really,
really difficult to get out of that
because you can't get a bank account,
for example,
and you can't pay your rent.
And there's,
there's,
there's economies of scale that you
can't take advantage of because you
don't have any money at all and so you
can't get going in the game.
And then so there's the problem of
starting out with zero,
which is a big problem and very
difficult to get out of.
And then there's the problem of falling
to zero if you are in the game because
when you fall to zero,
that it's very difficult to get going
again.
And so.
All right,
so now I want to show you something
about how,
how trading games work.
Um,
so I think we stopped,
we closed with this last time,
but so this is a,
this is a graph that shows you how a
monopoly game starts roughly speaking,
but you could say this is how you would
set up the world if you wanted perfect
equity.
If you wanted everybody to have the same
outcome,
everybody would have the same amount of
money.
In this case it's $10.
And so it's dollars along the,
along the bottom axis.
And it's number of players along the
lefthand day.
Oxys.
And you can think about this as a
monopoly game.
Everybody starts with the same amount of
money and then you start trading
randomly and you know if,
if,
if you have $10 in your trading,
a dollar each trade,
if you have enough people,
some unlucky person is going to end up
with $0 after 10 traits.
And if they end up with $1 after nine
trades,
they still have the chance of recovery.
It's a low chance,
but it's not zero.
But once they hit zero,
they're out of the game.
And so what happens is if you run this
simulation,
you have people flip a coin to determine
how they're going to trade,
then this is what happened.
So the first thing that happens is you
generate a normal distribution because
some people win and some people lose.
And most people sort of half women and
half lose.
But some lose continually.
And some wind continually.
And so it turns into a normal
distribution.
That's fine.
But then when the game continues to
play,
then what happens is that people start
to stack up on the zero end of things.
And a tiny proportion at the upper end
and if you play the game right to
cessation,
which is what you do,
if you play monopoly,
for example,
somebody ends up with all the money.
And the funny thing about playing
monopoly as you know,
if you've played monopoly multiple
times,
is that the probability that you'll win
continually across games is pretty low.
You know,
there's a lot of randomness in monopoly
and if you play with the same five
people,
10 games,
the probability is pretty good.
You're not going to win more than two
games.
So.
So there's chance elements that come
into play that determine the outcome.
And so anyways,
I was thinking about this more,
a little bit more last night and
somebody asked me,
I was talking about it with somebody and
uh,
he asked me if the Prieto distribution
was a necessary consequence of the fact
that production is number one measured.
And number two,
social.
And that's that.
I thought that was really interesting
question.
It's like,
do you get a prieto distribution every
time creative output ends up being
measured in some way.
And even if you can conceptualize it,
so because it might be the,
the idea might be that anything that you
can assign monetary value to is first of
all,
is something you can measure because
assigning monetary value to something is
in fact measuring it,
right?
You're measuring it with money and then
as soon as you assign a monetary value
to it,
you can,
you can trade,
you can trade it.
And it also takes on some aspects of a
zero sum game.
And most of the things that we talked
about with regards to
the production of Prieto distributions
were measured entities.
And we're,
um,
we're,
we're trading games as well.
So even because I mentioned to you,
for example,
that number of,
of basketball hoops successfully managed
it by NBA players is praetor
distributed.
But that's also,
those are measurable with
money because of course you get paid to
do it and it's,
it is a social game.
And so maybe it is an inevitable
consequence of trading in a social game
that you produce preload cubs.
And then I was trying to figure out why.
And I've also always had this suspicion
that what happens to people is that as
they move toward zero,
positive feedback loops get set up so
they're more likely to hit zero.
And as they move away from zero positive
feedback loops get set up so that
they're increasingly more likely to move
away from zero.
So here's an example.
Let's say you're not doing too bad,
so maybe you're in the middle of the
normal distribution,
then you lose your job.
Okay?
And so let's say you're a conscientious
person and we could say just for the
sake of argument,
that you lose your job because of mass
layoffs in your company.
So it has nothing to do with you.
It's fundamentally,
it's just luck of the draw basically.
But then what happens to you?
Well,
if you're conscientious,
you're gonna,
you're gonna.
Go after yourself pretty hard.
So you're going to,
especially if you're also high in
neuroticism,
it's going to depress you to lose your
job.
And maybe you're in a situation where
you just,
for one reason or another,
you don't have that many other
opportunities.
Now maybe you should look for them,
but maybe you're in a depressed state of
the economy or you're geographically
located somewhere that makes moving
difficult or so on and so forth.
You know,
so,
but you lose a job and then you start to
get depressed because of that.
Well,
then as you start to get depressed,
you know it decreases the probability
that you're going to look for a job,
but also maybe starts to put stress on
your family and it also starts to
decrease the probability that you're
going to engage in positive social
interaction.
So now not only are you unemployed and
suffering from economic stress,
but your marriage is starting to suffer
and you're starting to isolate yourself
from your friends.
And then of course,
as your marriage suffers in the stress
builds up,
then that's gonna make you more
depressed and that's going to keep you
even farther away from your friends.
And that's going to decrease the
likelihood that you're going to have
enough positive emotion and enthusiasm
to look for another job.
And then,
you know,
maybe you want to add a bit of a
drinking problem too.
That just for fun and you can see that
you can get a spiral going that's just
taken you down.
Right,
and it's all sorts of things because
lots of times people conceptualize,
let's say you're unemployed guide and
you go to counseling and you get a
diagnosis of depression and the thing
about a diagnosis of depression,
it's sort of like the assumption is
there's something gone wrong with your
psychological structure.
It's like if you're unemployed and
you're,
you're depressed.
It isn't obvious at all that the problem
is in your head.
You know what I mean?
It's.
It doesn't.
It isn't even obvious that it's a
psychological problem.
It's just a problem and problems can
take you out.
And so the.
You know,
if you're unemployed and you're under
economic stress and your marriage is
starting to shake and you're isolating
yourself from your friends and you're
less likely to be motivated to go look
for a job.
You can sort of think about that as a
depressive spiral,
but you can also think of it as a
conspiracy in some sense of external
forces that are auguring you into the
ground and we don't tend to
conceptualize psychological disorders
that way,
but we should because lots of times when
people are suffering from something that
you could describe in psychological
terminology and depression is a very
good example of that.
It isn't obvious that there's something
wrong with them.
Psychologically.
Often they just are in trouble and there
isn't a category in psychological
diagnosis for client in serious trouble.
But my experience has been almost
without exception that the people that
come to see me come to see me because
something's gone wrong with their life.
Not because they have a psychological
problem.
Now you could say,
well,
there are psychological inadequacies
such as they might be,
are interfering with their ability to
recover or maybe even served as
precursors to,
you know,
increase the probability of the
catastrophe,
but it's still not exactly the
appropriate way to conceptualize it.
And you know,
because you're,
you inside you.
And as a personality psychologist and as
a clinical theorists,
most of what I've talked to you guys
about is your psyche and its structure
as if it was like a soul that inhabited
you.
And there's some real utility in that.
You know,
you're an individual demarcated from the
community.
You can be set up in a healthy manner,
an unhealthy manner.
The problem with that is that you're not
just an individual,
you're connected to all these external
network dynamic networks that are
really,
really important.
And it isn't even easy to separate them
from,
you know,
like you might say,
well this is especially true once you
become a parent is like,
is your child more you than your arm?
You know what you think?
That's pretty obvious parts of you that
are physically linked,
our more key to you to you as an entity,
but it's by no means obvious.
I think many people would much more
happily sacrifice at arm than a child.
You know.
And so your boundaries are not where
your boundaries are located,
are not precisely isomorphic with the
outline of your body.
It's not that simple at all.
And so you're embedded in all sorts of
networks that can pull you down rapidly
or elevate you,
because the other thing that happens is
that,
well,
let's say I've never traded with anyone
and I go up to someone and I say,
well,
do you want to trade?
And they say,
well,
why?
How?
How can I trust you?
And the answer to that is,
well,
you have to take my word for it with
that's not,
that's not a very good argument.
You might say,
instead,
well here's what I have to offer and you
can evaluate it,
but the person is likely to say,
well,
I don't know how to evaluate it.
And so I'm still stuck with taking your
work.
So that's a bad problem.
And you'll see that if you ever tried to
sell a product in the marketplace is if
you don't.
If if the product is new and it's
complex,
then you're forcing the person that
wants to buy it to evaluate it and then
you're forcing them to take the risk of
being wrong as well as the time it would
take to evaluate it.
And they don't like that.
What they want is what's often called
social proof,
which is,
okay,
well you want to trade with me,
who else have you traded with?
And if the answer is zero,
then they are going to say,
well,
you're an interesting person and all
that.
But,
um,
I've got these other people over here
who have already traded with a bunch of
people and therefore the risk is lower
in part because let's say I have a
supervisor and I'm going to make a
decision.
And my primary concern is that my
supervisor will not hate me for making
the decision.
It's not my,
that my primary concern is to make the
best decision.
It's not the same thing.
It's that I want to make a decision that
I'm not going to get in trouble for,
okay,
so how do I do that?
Because I need a post hoc justification
so I buy something from you and it turns
out to be terrible.
And,
and I get called for it,
called on the table for it.
And what do I say?
I say,
well,
you know,
that person was buying from it and that
person was buying from,
from,
from him and that person was buying from
him like all these other people were
doing the same thing.
So it's not like the error is localized
in me and that's often a very credible
story.
But if the answer is,
well,
you know,
I,
I evaluated it and took A.
Rick decided to take a risk.
It's like out the door with you sunny,
because you know,
that's just,
that's an indication that you're not
capable of doing that sort of thing.
So I think part of the reason that
people spiral downhill into zero is
because Paul positive,
like a positive feedback loop is a loop
that increases the probability that the
loop will continue,
right?
A positive feedback loop is you've
experienced this when you hear
microphone feedback in an amplified
system.
So you know the microphone sends a
message to the speakers and then the
speakers send out the message amplified
and then the microphone picks up the
message and and it gets amplified again
and you get this howling occur,
which is can be deafening but can also
destroy the system because it'll keep
amplifying upward until the speakers
blow,
for example.
That's a positive feedback loop and a
positive feedback loop can spiral you
upward or it can spiral you downward.
And so a virtuous circle,
a virtuous positive feedback loop is
when,
well,
I've traded with him and I've traded
with him and I've traded with him and
now I can say to you,
I've traded with these three people and
you go talk to them when they say good
things and so then you say,
well,
I'll trade with you.
And then because of that,
then you're even more likely to trade
with me.
And it's like the thing starts to spiral
uphill and it does that.
I think in a nonlinear form.
And so because one of the things you
guys are going to be asking yourself as
you mature,
because what's happening is that income
inequality is increasing,
right?
And you might ask,
well why that?
Why is that?
The first thing you need to know is that
that's what income does.
So it's not like you need an explanation
for it.
This is the explanation.
It's like a natural rule.
If you run a trading game to its logical
conclusion,
one person ends up with all the money
and everyone else ends up with zero,
so you don't need an explanation for
that because that's,
that's it's in the natural order of
things that that occurs,
so to speak.
It's a logical consequence of a random
trading game with zero.
As one of the polls,
you still might ask yourself,
well,
what can you do about income inequality?
And that's a perfectly reasonable
question.
And as I said already,
the answer to that is what's if it's an
extraordinarily complicated problem to
to address,
we don't really know how to address it.
The only time it's really been
successfully as far as I can tell,
roughly speaking,
is during the industrial revolution,
especially in the part of the industrial
revolution that occurred,
say after World War II in the developing
world where for one reason or another,
it turned out that there were a
tremendous number of high paying
industrial jobs that people who,
that people could get access to without
having had the fortune,
the good fortune of one of these
positive feedback loops working for
them,
but those jobs are disappearing very,
very,
very rapidly and,
and one of the problems is,
as far as I can tell,
is that computational devices are in
intelligence and conscientiousness
multiplier.
And that's a big problem because the
more intelligent people are already and
more conscientious people are already
more likely to be tapped up on the,
on the winner's side of the prieto
distribution.
Then you add,
you know,
if you have an Iq of 150,
let's say you have an Iq of 150,
you know how to use a computer and you
live in Silicon Valley.
So man,
you're a deadly person,
right?
Because you're super fast,
let's say you're super hard working.
We could also say maybe you're super
energetic and healthy because that also
seems to be a criteria and that is a
real important determinant of that kind
of lifetime hyper success.
So you need you're way the hell above
average in ICU.
You're very,
very industrious.
You know how to use computers.
There are massive,
insanely massive effort multiplier and
then you're surrounded by people who are
super smart.
It's like there's a lot of things going
for you,
right?
You're going to be moving ahead at an
awful,
awful rate.
That's again,
why places like Silicon Valley are so
damn effective is that they're bringing
people from all over the world who are
like that into one place like silicon
valley.
I don't know if you guys know about the
Indian Institute of Technology,
but it's India's answered to mit and
it's one hell of an engineering school
and but a huge number of the graduates
from India go to Silicon Valley and work
there mostly as entrepreneurs.
They're very good at being entrepreneurs
as it turns out,
and they ship money like mad back to
India and that's part of what's driving
the Indian economy.
But it's just another example is that
because silicon valley is already full
of brilliant entrepreneurial people,
then more brilliant and entrepreneurial
people from all over the world flock
there like mad and it's just,
it's one of these cycles that spirals
upward,
very,
very difficult to,
to set that up somewhere else.
And once it gets going,
it's an unbelievably powerful economic
engine crazily,
crazily powerful.
So.
Okay,
so,
so what's the panoply let's say,
of of predictors that we know of?
Well,
um,
and so these are determinants of
lifetime success as far as I can tell.
Uh,
and I would think about this because
I'll tell you what it is that you need
to do to be successful.
Some of these things aren't so
malleable,
but others are things that you can work
on.
Well,
Iq.
Well that's a rough one because there is
no evidence as far as I can tell that
you can do a damn thing about your Iq.
I was just reading a paper by Dan Simon
today.
Uh,
it's a relatively recent review.
Dan Simon did the invisible gorilla
stuff and he was looking because there's
all these companies that claim that
these online brain training exercises
can produce cognitive improvements,
and he reviewed the literature.
Gannon,
I reviewed that literature like six
times in the last 15 years because I
keep hoping that someone will crack the
problem,
but it's always the same answer.
It's like you do brain training games.
You get better at the game a lot better
at that game.
You get slightly better at similar
games,
but distal games that are still heavily
cognitively loaded doesn't affect your
performance at all.
Zero.
None.
So the,
the,
the issue of how to raise Iq,
man,
that's a killer.
No one knows what,
how to do it.
I can tell you how to stop your Iq from
decreasing as you get older.
That's not so bad because it does that.
A fluid Iq decreases from the time
you're 20 and,
and pretty rapidly.
It's a physical.
Health is the best preventative.
So exercise,
physical exercise,
weirdly enough,
you know,
you think,
well,
why?
While your brain uses oxygen like Matt
right handed and it and it needs to be
kept clean and well oxygenated and
physical exercise,
both both like weightlifting,
so anaerobic and aerobic,
anaerobic and aerobic exercise both seem
to be very,
very effective at staving off cognitive
declines across the lifespan.
So that's a really useful thing to know
because that's the only thing we know
that does that.
So then the next best predictor of
lifetime success is conscientiousness.
While so and of the of the two aspects
of conscientiousness say orderliness and
industriousness,
the better predictor is industriousness.
So the question is,
well,
what can you do about your
industriousness?
And the answer to that is,
well that's Kinda rough too because
there's a strong genetic component,
but you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and I
think the best micro habits.
This is partly to do with this future
authoring program processes.
I think the best thing you can do with
regards to your conscientiousness is to
set up some aims for yourself.
Goals that you actually value and the
future authoring program helps people do
that.
And basically it does a situational
analysis of it helps you do a
situational analysis of your life more
than a psychological analysis,
I would say.
And so the questions are something like,
well,
alright,
you're going to have to put some effort
into your life and you need to be
motivated to do that.
And so what are the potential sources of
motivation?
You could think about them in the big
five manner.
If you're extroverted,
you want friends,
if you're agreeable,
you want an intimate relationship.
If you're disagreeable,
you want to win competitions.
If you're open,
you want to engage in creative activity.
If you're high in neuroticism,
you want security.
Okay?
So those are all sources of potential
motivation that you could draw on that
you could tailor to your own,
you know,
your own personality.
But then there are dimensions that you
want to consider your life across.
And so we asked people about,
well,
you know,
if you could have your life the way you
wanted it in three to five years,
if you were taking care of yourself
properly,
what would you want from your
friendships?
What would you want from your intimate
relationship?
How would you like to structure your
family?
What do you want for your career?
Well,
how are you going to use your time
outside of your job and how are you
going to regulate your mental,
physical,
mental,
and physical health and maybe also your
drug and alcohol use because that's a
good place to auger down because
alcoholism for example,
wipes out five to 10 percent of people,
so you want to keep that under control
and then and then so maybe you know,
you,
you develop a vision of what your life,
what you would like your life to be and
that associates the.
So the goal,
once the goal is established and then
you break down the goal into micro
processes that you can implement,
the microprocesses become rewarding in
proportion in relation to their causal
association with the goal and that
tangles in your,
your incentive reward system.
You know,
we talked about the dopaminergic
incentive reward system,
but that's the thing that keeps you
moving forward.
And the way it works is that it works
better if it produces positive emotion.
When it can see you moving towards a
valued goal,
okay,
well what's the implication of that?
Better have a valued goal because
otherwise you can't get any positive
motivation working out.
And so the more valuable the goal in
principle,
the more the microprocessor is
associated with that goal start to take
on a positive charge.
And so what that means is while you get
up in the morning and you're excited
about today,
you're ready to go.
And so as far as I can tell,
what you do is you specify your longterm
ideal.
Maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful.
You specify your goal.
You do that.
You do that in some sense as a unique
individual.
You want to.
You want to specify goals that make you
say,
Oh,
if that could happen as a consequence of
my efforts,
it would clearly be worthwhile.
Because the question always is,
why do something?
Because doing nothing is easy.
You just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy.
The question is why would you ever do
anything?
And the answer that has to be because
you've determined by some means that
it's worthwhile.
And then the next question might be,
well,
where should you look for worthwhile
things and one would be,
well,
you could consult your own temperament
and the other would be while you kinda
look at how,
look at what it is that people accrue
that's valuable across the lifespan.
Look,
look what?
So you do a structural analysis of the
subcomponents of human existence and
already did that.
You need a family.
You need friends,
like you don't need to have all of these
things,
but you better have most of them.
Family,
friends,
career,
educational goals,
plans for time outside of work,
attention to your mental and physical
health,
etc. You know those are,
that's what life is about.
And if You don't have any of those
things,
well then all you've got left is misery
and suffering.
So that's a bad.
That's a bad deal for you.
So,
so once you bought,
once you set up that goal structure,
let's say,
and that's really in many in many ways,
that's what you should be doing at
universities.
That's exactly what you should be doing
is trying to figure out who it is that
you're trying to be,
right,
and the aim at that and then use
everything you learned as a means of
building that person that you want to
be.
And and I really mean want to be,
I don't mean should be even those
things,
those things are going to overlap and
it's important to distinguish between
those because that's partly,
and this is back down to the micro
routine analysis.
So I started saying,
well,
you're going to try to make yourself
more industrious.
Okay?
Number one,
specify your damn goals because how are
you going to hit something if you don't
know what it is that isn't going to
happen.
And often people won't specify their
goals too because they don't like to
specify conditions for failure.
So if you keep yourself all vague and
foggy,
which is real easy because that's just a
matter of not doing as well,
then you don't know when you fail and
people might say,
well,
I really don't want to know when I fail
because that's painful,
so I'll keep myself blind about when I
fail.
ThAt's fine,
except you'll fail all the time.
Then you just won't know it until you
failed so badly that you're done.
And that can easily happen by the time
you're 40.
So.
So I would recommend that you don't let
that happen.
So that's willful blindness,
right?
You could have known,
but you chose not to.
Okay.
So once you get your goal structure set
up,
you think,
okay,
if I could have this life looks like
that might be worth living despite the
fact that it's going to be,
you know,
anxiety provoking and threatening,
and there's gonna be some suffering and
loss involved and all of that.
Obviously the goal is to have a vision
for your life such that all things
considered that justifies your effort.
Okay?
So then what do you do?
Well then then you turned down to the
micro routines.
It's like,
okay,
well this is what I'm aiming for.
How does that instantiate itself day to
day,
week to week,
month to month,
and that's where something like a
schedule can be unbelievably useful.
google calendar.
It's like make a damn schedule and stick
to it.
Okay,
so what's the rule with the schedule?
It's not a bloody prison.
That's the first thing that people do
wrong.
He said,
well,
I don't like to follow a schedule.
And it's like,
well,
what kind of schedule are you setting
up?
Well I,
I have to do this,
then I have to do this,
you know?
And then I just go play video games
because who wants to do all these things
that I have to do?
It's like wrong.
Set the damn schedule up so that you
have the day you want.
That's the trick.
It's like,
okay,
I've got tomorrow.
If I was going to set it up so it was
the best possible day I could have
practically speaking,
what would it look like?
Well then you schedule that and
obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense,
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day,
you're not in worse shape than you were
then at the beginning of the day,
right?
Because that's a stupid day.
If you have a bunch of thoSe in a row,
you just dig,
dig yourself a hole,
and then you bury yourself in.
It's like,
sorry,
that's just not a good strategy.
It's a bad strategy.
So maybe Twenty percent of your day has
to be responsibility and obligation,
or maybe it's more than that,
depending on how far behind you are,
but even that you can.
You can ask yourself,
okay,
well I've got these responsibilities.
I have to schedule the damn things in.
What's the right ratio of responsibility
to reward?
And you can ask yourself that just like
you'd negotiate with someone who is
working for you.
It'S like,
okay,
you gotta work tomorrow.
Okay,
so I want you to work tomorrow.
And you might say,
okay,
well what are you going to do for me
that makes it likely that I'll work for
you while you could ask yourself that,
you know,
maybe do an hour of of responsibility
and then you play a video game for 15
minutes.
I don't know,
whatever turns your crank man,
but you know,
you have to negotiate with yourself and
not tyrannized yourself like you're
negotiating with someone that you care
for that you would like to be productive
and have a good life.
And that's how you make the schedule.
It's like.
And then you look at the day and you
think,
well,
if I had that day,
that'd be good.
Great.
You know,
and you,
you're useless and horrible.
So you'll probably only hit it with
about 70 percent accuracy,
but that beats the hell out of zero.
Right?
And if you hit it even with 50 percent
accuracy,
another rule is well,
aim for 51 percent the next week or 50
and a half percent for god's sake.
Or because you're gonna hit that
position where things start to loop back
positively in spiral you upward.
And so,
so that's one way that you can work on
your conscientiousness is a plan,
a life you'd like to have,
and and you do that partly by referring
to social norms.
That's more or less rescuing your father
from the belly of the whale,
but the other way you do that is by
having a little conversation with
yourself about as if you don't really
know who you are,
because you know what you're like.
You won't do what you're told.
You won't do what you tell yourself to
do.
You must have noticed that.
It's like you're a bad employee and a
worse boss and both of those work for
you.
You don't know what you want to do.
And then when you tell yourself what to
do,
you don't do it anyways.
You should fire yourself and find
someone else to beat.
But,
but my point is that you have to
understand that you're not your own
servant,
so to speak.
You're someone that you have to
negotiate with and that's someone that
you want to present the opportunity of
having a good life too.
And that's hard for people because they
don't like themselves very much,
so you know,
they're always like cracking the whip
and then procrastinating and cracking
the whip and then procrastinating and
it's like,
god,
it's so boring and such a pathetic way
of spending your time.
And you know what that's like because
you probably waste like six hours a day.
And I think we did an economic
calculation about that a while back,
right?
your time is probably worth 50 bucks an
hour,
something like that.
I mean,
you're not getting paid that now,
but you're young.
And so this is investment time and what
you do now is going to multiply its
effects in the future.
So,
so let's say it's 50 bucks an hour,
which is perfectly reasonable.
So if you waste six hours a day and you
are,
then you're wasting about $2,000 a week
or about $100,000 a year.
So like go ahead.
That's what it's costing you every hour.
And you need to know what your damn time
is worth.
So let's say it's not 50 bucks,
it's 30,
whatever,
maybe it's a hundred,
it's somewhere in that range.
One of The things that you should be
asking yourself is when you spend an
hour was that,
well,
what have I paid someone 50 bucks to
have had that hour?
And if that answer is no,
it's like,
well maybe you should do something else
with your time.
And it depends on whether or not you
think that your time is worthwhile.
But the funny thing about not assuming
that is if you assume your time isn't
worthwhile,
what happens is you don't just sit
around sort of randomly in a state of
responsibility lists bliss.
What you do is you suffer existentially
and so that seems like a stupid
solution.
So okay.
So anyways,
as far as I can tell,
that's how you can improve your
conscientiousness.
Hit an outline and goal that you
actually would like to hit and even
better,
here's something else you can think
about when you're negotiating in your
life.
You could say if you're going to
pessimistic,
you'd say,
well,
we have to negotiate an agreement.
I'd like to walk away,
not miserable and resentful.
Okay,
let's call that a baseline and that's
how you're going to negotiate with your
wife or your husband.
That's a good thing to know.
You want to negotiate so that you don't
walk away miserable and resentful
because that makes you hostile and then
you'll work to hurt them and I would say
that's unless you want to hurt them and
then of course they'll happily return
the favor unless you.
If you want to exist in a place where
you're basically hitting each other in
the head repeatedly for 30 years,
you go right ahead,
but I wouldn't say that that's a
particularly good way of living.
So you might say,
well,
the minimal precondition for a
successful negotiation is that you don't
walk away resentful and angry.
And so that's also how you know when you
have something to say to someone because
the rule has to be.
If you're going to walk away resentful
and angry,
you've got something to say.
it doesn't mean you're right,
by the way,
but it does mean that you have something
to say,
but it's kind of a low bar.
You know,
like if I wanted to live with you for 30
years,
maybe we should say,
how about we walk away from our mutual
negotiations?
Thrilled.
Well why not?
You know,
you got to aim for something you could
aim for that you want to negotiate with
your boss for a new seller.
You might think,
okay,
I've got this damn job.
How much would I have to be paid,
so I'd be so bloody excited to go to
work.
I could hardly stand it while you can at
least know what that number is,
and then you could go there and say,
well look,
you know,
you like to have me around.
I've been doing some thinking.
I think if you paid me this amount of
money,
I'd be so thrilled to go to work that
you could hardly even keep me away from
here.
And your boss might think,
wow,
I actually really liked to have someone
around who would be so thrilled to work
that I can't get rid of them.
It's like,
maybe all,
well,
I can't give you all of that.
I'll give you 75 percent.
Maybe we can renegotiate it in a year,
so like,
hey,
good deal,
or you can be some weasley coward and go
in there and snuggle about how awful
your life is and walk away,
barely able to tolerate the outcome of
the.
So like I wouldn't recommend that and
it's funny because I've watched people
do this repeatedly in my clinical
practice because I do,
we do.
We plan all the time because the rule is
you're going to come and see me.
I'm going to try to help you figure out
how to have the life that you want to
have and we're going to think about that
strategically.
So you're making $50,000 a year right
now.
Maybe you should be making $150,000 in
three years.
And they think,
well that couldn't happen.
It's like not with that attitude.
That's the first thing.
It's like,
no,
that's not going to happen if you,
if you don't ask people for the damn
money,
if you don't look for a better job,
but they're going to come along and just
shovel a boat full of money at you.
It's like,
no,
that's not going to happen,
but why is that impossible?
Look at you people in here.
It's like,
what the hell is wrong with you?
Nothing.
So you probably have what you want.
If you could figure out whAt the hell it
was and then you know,
you diligently pursued it.
So.
and then maybe you wouldn't whIne about
being alive.
That'd be good because people who whine
about being alive or dangerous to
themselves and other people.
So you might think I can have what I
want,
but you better well figure out what it
is and you can't just wait for the like
have what you want fairy to show up at
your doorstep and granted because
obviously that's not going to happen.
So.
Okay.
Conscientiousness,
while we talked about how you could
improve that social networking,
that's another big deal.
It's one of the advantages that older
people have over younger people.
And so for example,
now that I'm in my fifties,
roughly speaking,
I know a bunch of other people who are
relatively well positioned in the
dominance hierarchy and they know all
sorts of people.
And so when I go to one of them and say,
can you do x or do you know x?
They say no,
but I know someone who can.
And that's a huge advantage.
So another thing that you want to think
about as you move through life and this
is,
is that use your ability to network
properly.
And that doesn't mean schmooze and it
doesn't mean go out and impress people.
That's all just complete bloody rubbish.
It means you,
you,
you try to surround yourself with people
who are competent in multiple different
dimensions and you maintain your
relationships with them.
And that's a trading relationship to
right.
It involves from reciprocity,
but it's a huge advantage.
A social network is a huge advantage and
that's something extroverted people can
be really good at because you know they
have that sort of social ability and
that goes along with the ability to
sell.
So another place that you can pick up
power and power for the good,
for the right things is to,
is to consciously develop and maintain
your social networks.
And that also means,
while,
let's talk about friendships for a
minute,
here's how you know,
if someone's,
your friend a you can tell them bad news
and they'll listen.
They won't tell you why you know you're
stupid and why that bad thing happened
to you and how something worse happened
to them once and you know,
derailed the whole conversation.
You can actually tell them bad news and
they'll listen.
So that's a good thing.
And then this is a weirder thing.
You can tell them good news
and they'll help you celebrate.
And that's a really good way of deciding
who you should have around you.
Because if you have someone around you,
you know some good habits you and you're
kind of afraid to even admit it because
you know god,
something good happened to you.
It's like you let that be known and it
will certainly be taken away.
So you know,
you come out and you sort of tell
someone halfheartedly that something
good happened to you,
they give you a whack and then talk
about,
you know,
so the great thing that happened to them
three years ago or worse,
the great thing that happened to someone
that they knew three years ago,
you know,
it's like go away from that person.
They're not helpful to you and they're
not helpful to themselves either.
And so you want to surround years,
you've got to think about this.
You've got to surround yourself with
people who want the best for the best
part of you.
You can hang around with weasels and
losers that are trying to pull you down
to justify the fact that they're
spiraling downhill as well.
And you know,
the upside of that is you don't have to
have any responsibility,
can whine about how wretched life is,
you know,
so that's pretty attractive.
But I would say it's also a bad medium
to longterm plan.
And so it's,
it's acceptable and desirable to try to
surround yourself with people who were
facilitating your development.
You know when you might say,
well,
I've got people around,
I know them well,
you know they're,
they're,
they're not doing that well and they're
and they don't fit into that category.
It's like,
what's your point?
What are you going to do with them?
Exactly.
If they'll,
if they'll listen and cooperate with you
and move towards a better future,
great.
if they don't pay any attention and they
keep doing the same damn things over and
over and they're not going anywhere and
is painful,
then maybe the proper thing to do is
say,
you just have your misery.
I'll go off and have my life and maybe
you'll wake up at some point in the
future and think that's a better way of
being because just putting up with it is
while they call that enabling,
right?
You put up with that sort of behavior.
You're providing tacit consent for it
and even tacit approval.
It's like bad idea.
You have,
I would say both the right and the
responsibility to surround yourself with
people who are good for the best part of
you and that's not the same as you know.
Don't have to elaborate on that.
You can figure out what that means.
Skills,
that's another thing you can do,
and if you want to increase your
probability of success every time you
have an opportunity to take an
opportunity that would provide you with
a new skill.
Do it right.
Learn to program,
learn to write,
learn to read,
read new things,
learn to public speak.
Learn how to introduce yourSelf to
people.
Learn how to socIal network,
learn how to go talk to your boss in a
matter.
This is the right way to go.
Talk to someone who's supervising you.
I see this problem and here's the
solution and so I'm coming to talk to
you about the problem and the solution.
It's like that person is going to want
to talk to you a lot because the other
people they're talking to,
you are going to come and say,
I've got a problem.
Can you do something about it?
Like they don't want to do something
about it.
They already got things to do.
You know?
So if you're the person who constantly
brings forth a problem,
even if they're accurate problems,
is why are they going?
They're going to want to have you
around.
It's you're just,
you're just another problem.
Don't be a problem for the people who
want to give you money.
That's a good rule of thumb,
man.
You know,
if someone wants to give you money,
then help them do that.
And if they want to give you status and
success,
then help them do that.
right?
And you do that in part by bringing them
solutions and partly you do that by
developing your skills.
And so if things aren't going very well
for you,
this is also a good way of evaluating an
opportunity.
Should you take an opportunity.
Well,
here's the rule,
take the opportunity if it will teach
you something that you can use for other
opportunities because then even if it
fails,
which it probably will,
doesn't matter because you've accrued
something of value that you can bring
forward to the next situation.
So you know,
there's this old union idea that I told
you about the sharp cathedral,
for example,
the cathedral is made in the form of a
cross and the cross signifies the center
of the world and the dome signifies the
sky and so right below the dome at the
center of the world,
and it's a cross because the cross is
the place of suffering.
So that's the center of the world
because that's what you are,
you're the place of suffering,
right?
You're the place of conscious suffering.
That's the center Of the world.
And so inscribed on the floor is a maze
and you and it's a big maze and it's a
mandela and,
and there's a kind of a flower shaped
resting place right in the center.
And what you're doing is walking in the
maze and you walk all four quadrants and
you get to the middle,
which is where you want to be.
You want to be in the middle.
Well,
how do you get there?
You walk everywhere aNd what does that
mean?
It means every bloody time you're
offered an opportunity,
take it and develop your skills.
And that's better than wealth by the
way,
in fact,
it actually constitutes wealth because
wealth constitutes what you have when
someone takes all your money away,
right?
That's real wealth.
And so the way that you build up that
sort of wealth is you turn yourself into
someone who's competent in multiple
directions and you can be doing that all
the time,
right?
Especially with the kind of technology
that you people have access to.
I mean,
you can learn anything you want whenever
you want.
So what a good deal that is,
man.
And so there's,
there's easy fruit hanging that you
could pick and I would recommend that
you do that.